Music.
Herzlich willkommen zum Dicke Bretter Podcast.
Wir sind ein Podcast von Constanze Kurz,
Elisa Lindinger und Elina Eickstedt und sprechen über Policy im weitesten Sinne,
nämlich meistens was dahinter steckt, was die Prozesse sind und machen das immer
anhand von aktuellen Beispielen.
In unserer allerersten Folge waren wir schon mal bei der UN und die UN ist ein
großes Thema, deswegen wollen wir heute auch nochmal über die UN sprechen und
ich bin heute hier mit Konstanze Kurz,
hallo, und Tanja Facherthaler von Epicenterworks, hallo.
Und bevor wir jetzt loslegen mit diesen Policy-Themen, wollen wir noch einmal
unsere Gästin, die Tanja, vorstellen.
Ich habe es eben schon gesagt, sie kommt von Epicenterworks.
Das ist eine Digital Rights NGO aus Österreich.
Der oder die ein oder andere mag sich schon kennen, vielleicht von Netzneutralitätsthemen
und auch häufig in Person von Thomas Lohninger.
Aber es gibt noch mehr wundervolle, fleißige Policy-Menschen bei Epicenter,
nämlich zum Beispiel die Tanja.
Tanja, magst du dich vielleicht einmal selber vorstellen, mal erzählen,
was dich zu Epicenter verschlagen hat und was du sonst noch so machst?
Ja, sehr gerne. Zuerst vielen Dank euch beiden für die Einladung.
Ich freue mich sehr, heute hier zu sein und ein bisschen über unsere Arbeit
bei den Vereinten Nationen zu berichten.
Zu mir selbst, ich bin Policy Advisor bei Epicenter Works, das ist seit mittlerweile zweieinhalb Jahren.
Mein Hintergrund ist eigentlich in den Rechtswissenschaften,
also ich habe Jura in Deutschland,
also in Österreich habe ich in Deutschland eben Jura studiert und danach auch
einen Master gemacht in Venedig und in Sevilla zu Menschenrechten und Demokratisierung
und habe Arbeitserfahrung in unterschiedlichsten Bereichen in der Legal Industry,
also im großen Bereich der der rechtswissenschaftlichen Berufe,
sowohl in Österreich als eben dann auch in Brüssel.
Ich habe von 2016 bis Anfang 2020 in Brüssel gearbeitet,
auch für Menschenrechtsorganisationen und für Beratungsunternehmen,
das sich sehr stark für Projekte eingesetzt hat bei den europäischen Institutionen.
Und bin dann kurz vor der Pandemie wieder nach Österreich zurückgekommen und
nach einem Abstecher in der Anwaltei eben seit Sommer 2021 bei Epicenter Works tätig.
Mich hat es vor allem wieder zurück in die Menschenrechtsarbeit gezogen.
Epicenter Works ist ja da in einem sehr interessanten, neuen,
spannenden Feld eben digitale Rechte oder Menschenrechte, Grundrechte im digitalen Raum tätig.
Für mich war das auch Grund und Anlass, mich hierfür zu bewerben und bin seit
der Teil eines Teams, das ist sehr divers und ich glaube, jeder für sich eine
sehr interessante Persönlichkeit hat und ich fühle mich da sehr wohl.
Ich bin jetzt seit einem Jahr für die Vereinten Nationen in unserer Organisation
zuständig und freue mich, euch ein bisschen heute darüber zu erzählen.
Ja, wir freuen uns auch, dass du da bist und wir haben dich aus einem bestimmten
Grund eingeladen, denn wir versuchen ja in dem Podcast Dicke Bretter immer so
ein bisschen bestimmte Strukturen zu beleuchten eigentlich,
wie die funktionieren, wie so Policies entstehen und dann nehmen wir uns halt
immer ein praktisches Beispiel.
Und dieses Beispiel hat ein bisschen komplexen Namen. Ich will ihn mal vollständig nennen.
Das ist die International Convention on Countering the Use of Information and
Communication Technologies for Criminal Purposes.
Und im Volksmund würde man sagen Cybercrime.
Aber da fängt es natürlich überhaupt schon an,
denn die Verhandlungen für diese Konvention laufen und haben sich natürlich
sofort auch um die Definition von Cybercrime gestritten, natürlich.
Also darüber wollen wir sprechen.
Was ist denn nun eigentlich drin in dieser Cybercrime Convention?
Wie grenzt man sie ab? Und ist nicht bald jedes Verbrechen digital?
Könnte man also alles mit reinnehmen?
Und ist der Zeitplan gehalten worden? Denn das läuft ja schon eine Weile.
Seit 2022 wird aktiv verhandelt.
Zunächst natürlich über den Scope dieser Convention, aber auch über die Struktur.
Und jetzt sind wir aber schon, sag ich gleich mal dazu, falls man den Podcast
erst im Jahr 2030 hört, wir sind gerade im Dezember 2023, also schon über ein Jahr Verhandlung,
und eigentlich sollte sie Anfang 2024 fertig sein. Wo stehen wir da also?
Und dann vielleicht ein paar kritische Punkte, die schon vor Beginn eigentlich
der Verhandlungen aufgeworfen sind.
Also wie verhält es sich bei den Forderungen, die teilweise von China und Russland
oder Indien oder auch der Türkei mit reingebracht werden sollen?
Also wie kann man zum Beispiel Menschenrechte trotzdem oder vor allen Dingen unterstreichen?
Etwa Meinungsfreiheit, aber auch Privacy-Grundrechte. Und ja,
vielleicht als Frage insbesondere für Tanja, die ja nun daran teilnimmt als
Teil der Zivilgesellschaft.
Wie nimmt die Zivilgesellschaft teil?
Wir gehen jetzt davon aus, dass die meisten, die heute zuhören,
sich jetzt nicht die stundenlang im UN-WebTV vorhandenen Aufzeichnungen dieser
einzelnen Komiteesitzungen ansieht.
Aber wir wollen gerne einen Einblick bekommen, wie funktioniert eigentlich so
eine Verhandlung und welche NGOs nehmen daran teil?
Und vielleicht noch, vielleicht am Anfang hätte ich eine Frage.
Wir sind nur alle drei deutschsprachig. Wir sind zwar nicht aus demselben Land,
aber wer sich bei den Dokumenten umgesehen hat, wird feststellen,
dass es sehr viele Übersetzungen gibt, wie das üblicherweise ist bei den Vereinten
Nationen, aber kein Deutsch.
Warum eigentlich? Warum kann
man den aktuellen Stand dieser Verhandlungen nicht auf Deutsch finden?
Weil Deutsch keine offizielle Sprache der UN ist. Also es gibt sechs Sprachen,
offizielle Sprachen der UN.
Das sind Englisch, Französisch, Spanisch, Russisch, Chinesisch und Arabisch.
Deutsch gehört da nicht dazu und das ist einfach der Gründung,
es geht zurück auf die Gründungszeiten der UN.
Aber ja, es stimmt, es ist schade, dass man das hier nicht auf Deutsch findet.
Es ist in diesem Gremium so leider der Fall. Es wird es offiziell auch nicht auf Deutsch geben.
Ja, dann steigen wir die Inhalte ein. War nur so eine Frage,
die sich mir bei der Recherche gestellt hat.
Das hat sich mir auch bei der Vorbereitung ein bisschen gestellt,
weil es ist heute das erste Mal, wo ich auf Deutsch über dieses Thema spreche.
Dementsprechend waren da auch ein paar Schwierigkeiten sprachlicher Natur drinnen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen ist es ja auch ungewöhnlich. Also wenn wir so in der EU
sind, dann warten wir ja immer darauf, dass die Texte auf allen Sprachen zur Verfügung stehen.
Sonst geht da ja eigentlich gar nichts. Das ist ja echt ungewohnt.
Das ist ein Unterschied zwischen UN und EU.
Das ist interessant, dass du sagst, dass du noch nie auf Deutsch darüber gesprochen hast.
Das heißt ja gleichzeitig, dass mediales Interesse offenbar wenig vorhanden ist. Ist das korrekt?
Es wird medial leider nicht sehr viel über diesen Vertrag oder diesen zukünftigen Vertrag berichtet.
Ich muss vielleicht dazu sagen, dass wir uns und mit mir, mit wir meine ich
jetzt nicht nur EpiCenterWorks,
sondern auch andere zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen, mit denen wir uns
in so ein loses Bündnis, so eine lose Koalition da jetzt zusammengeschlossen haben,
uns sehr bemüht haben, auch medial dem Thema mehr Präsenz zu geben.
Wir haben nach der vierten Verhandlungsrunde im Frühjahr in Wien eine Pressekonferenz,
Organisiert, die war aber nicht nur an österreichische oder deutsche Medien
gerichtet, sondern ganz allgemein international.
Wir haben dann auch auf Englisch gesprochen.
Es waren Kolleginnen und Kollegen dabei aus Indien, aus den USA, aus UK.
Dementsprechend so divers die Organisationen sind, die teilnehmen,
so divers war es dann auch und wir haben uns darauf geeinigt,
das doch in englischer Sprache zu machen,
einfach um entsprechend dann auch den Zugang zu den Informationen entsprechend
sicherzustellen für alle Media-Outlets und auch,
unsere diversen Standpunkte entsprechend vertreten zu können.
Aber ja, es stimmt natürlich, es könnte mehr Medienpräsenz geben für dieses Thema.
Es ist vermutlich der Tatsache geschuldet, dass es ein sehr technisches Thema
ist und man denkt sich, naja, es geht um die Bestrafung von Computerkriminalität, also von Cybercrime.
Was hat das denn eigentlich mit der Bevölkerung als solches zu tun oder was
kann denn da eigentlich jetzt wirklich gefährlich daran sein?
Ich glaube, Ich glaube, es ist einfach die Tatsache, dass es sehr technisch
ist und möglicherweise auch das UN-Gesetzgebungsverfahren nicht sehr offen,
nicht sehr transparent sind in den meisten Fällen.
Ich denke, es ist diesen Umständen geschuldet. Ja, dann wollen wir mal ein bisschen
was dafür tun, jedenfalls im deutschen Sprachraum.
Das Chaosradio hat ja auch teilweise ein sehr technisches Publikum,
vielleicht mal ein paar Personen darauf aufmerksam zu machen.
Und Constanze hat es jetzt gerade schon mal kurz eingeführt,
aber vielleicht kannst du uns da ja auch nochmal ein bisschen mehr zu sagen.
Worum geht es eigentlich in diesem Cyber-Cyber-Cybercrime-Treaty?
Wir kennen ja irgendwie so diese Diskussion über den Hackerparagrafen in Deutschland
und viele andere Sachen,
aber aus welcher Idee ist das entstanden und was sind eigentlich so die Punkte,
die es versucht zu adressieren?
Ja, gerne. Mit technisch meine ich jetzt juristisch-technisch,
sollte ich vielleicht dazu sagen. Ich hoffe, ich mache es nicht zu juristisch.
Ich werde mich sehr bemühen. Also worum geht es denn eigentlich bei diesem Treaty, bei diesem Vertrag?
Es ist vielleicht, wenn man zurückblickt, ein bisschen auf die Entstehungsgeschichte,
es ist Anfang schon gesagt worden, es wird jetzt schon eine Zeit lang verhandelt.
Ursprünglich war es so, dass 2017 Russland die Idee aufgebracht hat, aufgeworfen hat,
Computerkriminalität international auch zu reglementieren und unter Strafe zu
stellen und dementsprechende Regelungen dann auch für die Strafverfolgung und
die internationale Zusammenarbeit,
also die Rechtshilfe unter den Staaten zu schaffen.
Das ist auf wenig Gegenliebe gestoßen. Also sehr viele Staaten hatten da grobe
Bedenken und haben sich gedacht, an und für sich brauchen wir diesen Vertrag nicht.
Warum haben sie das gedacht? Es gibt auf Ebene des Europarats,
das ist eine von der EU unabhängige eigene internationale Organisation in Europa,
Europa, die aber einen weiteren Mitglieds-, also einen größeren Mitgliedsstaatenfall-,
also Bereich hat, sagen wir mal.
Also es dehnt sich dann aus bis Armenien, Aserbaidschan, Russland ist dabei,
die Türkei zum Beispiel.
Und da hat man 2001 eine Konvention genau zu diesem Thema schon verabschiedet.
Anwendbar eben nur bei, also unter Staaten des Europarats, die da beitreten wollten.
Das ist die sogenannte Budapester-Konvention. Also das ist so der Name,
unter dem sie bekannt ist.
Es ist die erste internationale oder in dem Fall eben regionale Konvention,
der erste internationale völkerrechtlich verbindliche Vertrag,
der Computerkriminalität eben auch regeln soll, unter Strafe stellen soll,
auch entsprechende prozessuale Maßnahmen beinhaltet und eben auch Rechtshilfemaßnahmen.
Regelt. Warum ist Russland dagegen gewesen?
Nein, vielleicht sollte ich dazu auch noch sagen, es haben sich darüber hinaus
Staaten diesem Vertrag auch angeschlossen, die gemeint haben,
wir nehmen das jetzt als Blueprint, als Vorbild, entweder für unsere eigenen
nationalen Gesetze oder wir treten überhaupt bei.
Also man hat mittlerweile auch Mitglieder wie Argentinien, Australien,
Brasilien, Chile, Kolumbien, Costa Rica, Peru, Mauritius, Japan,
Sri Lanka, Tonga oder sogar die USA.
Also wirklich, es ist jetzt keine vollständige Liste gewesen,
aber man sieht, es ist sehr breit über alle Weltteile verteilt.
Und um da Mitglied werden zu können, also um da beitreten zu können,
dieser Konvention ist vielleicht der bessere Ausdruck,
werden die ursprünglichen Vertragsstaaten, also eben die europäischen Europaratsmitgliedstaaten,
die eben der Konvention beigetreten sind, die diese ausgehandelt haben,
werden diese natürlich gefragt, ob es Bedenken gibt,
Staaten diesem Vertrag beitreten zu lassen, die eben außerhalb des europäischen
Kontinents angesiedelt sind.
Russland sieht das ganz stark als Eingriff in die eigene Souveränität.
Das hat auch wiederholt Zusammenarbeit in den Bereichen der Computerkriminalität
mit anderen Staaten verweigert und hat dann gemeint, wir machen das jetzt anders.
Wir versuchen auf UN-Ebene einen eigenen internationalen Vertrag über Computerkriminalität
auszuarbeiten, wo wir uns beispielsweise jetzt nicht dieser Vorabprüfung durch
andere Staaten stellen müssen.
Und so ist erstmal die Idee ausgekommen. Die meisten Staaten haben gemeint,
das brauchen wir nicht, wir haben Budapest ja ohnehin.
Wir sehen anhand der Tatsache, dass so viele Staaten sich dieser Konvention
anschließen, da dabei sein möchten, dass es ein Erfolg ist.
Es hat sich da aber ein bisschen geändert. Geopolitik ist immer ein bisschen,
wie soll ich sagen, undurchsichtig und auch immer wieder im Wandel.
Nicht nur der Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine hat da eine sehr große Rolle gespielt.
Also die meisten Staaten haben sich dann gedacht, naja, früher oder später werden
wir wohl auch auf UN-Ebene und international uns dem Thema widmen müssen,
eine Konvention, ein wie auch immer rechtlich verbindliches Dokument dazu ausarbeiten müssen.
Nutzen wir doch die Gelegenheit, Russland ist international geschwächt, ist isoliert.
Nutzen wir doch die Gunst der Stunde und versuchen hier hier einen Vertrag auszuarbeiten.
Und ja, so wurden letztendlich dann auch, kam es dann zur Abstimmung auch in
der Generalversammlung, der UN-Generalversammlung, das ist das Gremium,
das darüber entscheidet, ob Verhandlungen aufgenommen werden, unter anderem.
Und tatsächlich, man hat sich dann entschieden, diese Vertragsverhandlungen
zu starten und das ist dann auch so geschehen.
Ende des Jahres 2023 immer noch mittendrin. Okay, vielleicht sollte man vom
Zeitplan noch mal kurz hinzufügen.
Als der Ukraine-Krieg und damit natürlich auch die Haltung von den anderen Staaten
zu Russland, als der so richtig aggressiv begann, nämlich im Februar 2022,
da waren diese Verhandlungen schon gestartet. Ist das richtig?
Ja, das ist richtig. Richtig.
Man sollte vielleicht auch dazu sagen, dass es in der UN-Generalversammlung
über die Entscheidung, ob Verhandlungen jetzt aufgenommen werden,
keinen Erdrutschsieg in dem Sinn gegeben hat.
Also nur um die Diversität zu zeigen, man hatte in der Abstimmung 79 Stimmen
dafür, man hatte 60 dagegen und 33 Enthaltungen.
Also man sieht sehr gut daran auch, wie gespalten unter den Staaten die Meinung
ist, ob man jetzt diese Verhandlungen aufnehmen soll oder nicht.
Ob es einen Bedarf gibt, einen neuen Vertrag abzuschließen zu diesem Thema oder
eben nicht. Und man sieht das bis in die Verhandlungen jetzt.
2022 sind die Verhandlungen dann tatsächlich eröffnet worden.
Ja, das war dann genau zu dem Zeitpunkt, als der Ukraine-Krieg eben begonnen
hat und besonders eben einen brutalen Angriffskrieg begonnen hat.
Und da wurden die Verhandlungen dann auch tatsächlich aufgenommen.
Okay, jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen schon, ich sag mal so ein bisschen das
Policy-Vorspiel, hätte ich fast gesagt, gehört.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt sozusagen dazu gekommen, dass das aufgesetzt wurde.
Was sind denn so die Kernpunkte von diesem Treaty?
Also erstmal vielleicht so ganz generell, was die Kernpunkte sind.
Du hast ja schon gesagt, irgendwie Rechtsbeihilfe in Bezug auf Cyberkriminalität,
aber das ist natürlich wahrscheinlich ein weites Feld.
Wahrscheinlich gab es schon so Vordefinitionen aus der Budapester Konvention,
auf die man zurückgreifen konnte,
aber worüber, also was war jetzt sozusagen die Punkte, an denen gearbeitet wurden
und vor allen Dingen, was sind jetzt auch die Punkte, um die gestritten wird,
beziehungsweise wo wir auch Probleme sehen?
Ja, man hat sich tatsächlich sehr stark an der Budapester-Konvention orientiert.
Man sieht in sehr vielen der Artikel, man sah es von Anfang an,
man sieht es jetzt immer wieder auch im aktuellen Entwurf, dass sich sehr viele
Artikel an der Budapester-Konvention orientieren.
Auch im Aufbau ist es sehr stark an der Budapest-Konvention orientiert.
Daneben hat man auch zwei weitere UN-Verträge, UN-Dokumente herangezogen.
Nämlich zum einen die UN-Konvention gegen Korruption und die UN-Konvention gegen
transnationales organisiertes Verbrechen.
Das ist ja interessant erstmal, dass man diese beiden mit heranzieht. Genau.
Das Problem an der Sache ist natürlich, dass es sehr schwierig ist,
dass man aus drei verschiedenen internationalen Verträgen versucht, einen neuen zu basteln.
Also jetzt wirklich Bestimmungen zum Teil aus ihrem Kontext nimmt,
damit halt auch oft in dem Ursprungsvertrag eingezogene Sicherheitsdecken,
Sicherheitsgarantien nicht mitbedenkt, sondern einfach einzelne Elemente herausgreift
und in diesen neuen Vertragsentwurf hineinpflanzt.
Das ist sehr schwierig und das sieht man, und ich glaube im Verlauf des Gesprächs
werden wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen genauer darauf zu sprechen kommen,
weil das sieht man auch in den Verhandlungen immer wieder.
Aber nur um vielleicht am Anfang zu sagen, auf die Frage zurückzukommen,
worum es denn eigentlich geht.
Also wir haben schon gesagt, zum einen soll Computerkriminalität international
unter Strafe gestellt werden.
Da muss man betonen, es gibt keine Definition, keine international anerkannte
Definition von Computerkriminalität. Also welche Straftatbestände darunter fallen,
das ist ein Thema der Diskussionen und das ist umstritten.
Ich werde dazu später zu den Punkten, die aktuell großen Diskussionsbedarf hervorrufen,
auch noch näher eingehen.
Zum anderen natürlich sind es die weitreichenden prozessualen Kompetenzen,
die den Strafverfolgungsbehörden eingeräumt werden, also sogenannte Überwachungsmaßnahmen.
Auch die sind sehr weitreichend.
Auch darauf werde ich zum späteren Zeitpunkt im Gespräch noch eingehen vermutlich.
Aber nur so viel, die sind zum Großteil aus der Budapester Konvention übernommen.
Nur darf man da halt nicht vergessen, im Budapest, also bei der Budapester Konvention,
waren es europäische Europaratsmitglieder, also europäische Staaten,
die alle Mitglieder im Europarat sind,
von denen man ausgehen kann, dass sie eine gemeinsame geschichtliche,
rechtliche Tradition teilen, die auch alle Mitglieder sind, also die auch alle,
die Rechtsprechung des Europäischen Gerichtshofs für Menschenrechte,
akzeptieren, die auch die europäische Menschenrechtskonvention alle ratifiziert haben.
Und diese Bestimmungen möchte man jetzt nehmen, nimmt sie, verpflanzt sie in
diesen neuen Vertragstext und vergisst dabei, dass dieser Vertragstext ja auf
der gesamten Welt anwendbar sein soll.
In Staaten, die einer komplett anderen rechtlichen Tradition entspringen,
wo die Menschenrechtsstandards, sage ich jetzt mal, andere sind,
als wir sie in Europa kennen.
Und ich möchte jetzt auf gar keinen Fall so verstanden werden,
dass es in Europa toll ist und alles perfekt ist.
Keinesfalls. Auch hier gibt es tagtäglich Bedarf, sich um den Erhalt und um
den Schutz der Menschenrechte einzusetzen.
Aber dennoch sollen auch Staaten diesen Vertrag ratifizieren und annehmen,
die einem komplett anderen Verständnis und einem komplett anderen Level,
sage ich mal, Menschenrechtsschutz haben, wenn sie ihn überhaupt haben.
Es gibt ja auch nicht in allen Regionen der Welt sowas wie bei uns,
dem Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte zum Beispiel.
Aber da würde ich ja immer ganz kurz einhaken, weil das ist ja schon mal ganz
interessant, dass sie jetzt nicht nur versuchen sozusagen sich an dieser Definition
von Cybercrime zu versuchen, sondern gleichzeitig auch irgendwie es wieder um Überwachung geht.
Kannst du vielleicht mal ganz kurz sagen, du hast gerade gesagt,
die europäischen Staaten akzeptieren soweit die EuGH-Rechtsspeicherung.
Ich glaube irgendwie so unser Lieblingsbeispiel ist, Konstanz ist Lieblingsbeispiel,
ist bestimmt Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Aber was war denn in der Budapester-Konvention bisher an Überwachungsmaßnahmen
vorgesehen und was ist jetzt sozusagen das,
was jetzt noch on top kommt aus der internationalen Gemeinschaft?
Ja, also es ist ja, es war in den vergangenen Verhandlungsrunden so,
nämlich von der ersten bis zur vierten, da hatten die Verhandlungsrunden so ein bisschen,
haben mich so ein bisschen an den, wir sind jetzt in der Adventszeit,
also ich kann das wohl so sagen, an den Brief Hans-Christkind erinnert,
also die verschiedensten Staaten haben sich.
Maßnahmen oder eben auch Straftatbestände gewünscht, sag ich mal,
die sie gerne in diesem Vertrag sehen wollten.
Und das war sehr weitreichend und das war sehr divers.
Wenn ich es jetzt einmal nur festmache an den Überwachungsmechanismen,
die Vorratsdatenspeicherung wurde genannt,
auch die hat man sich gewünscht, auch die war tatsächlich eine Zeit lang,
stand sie auch drinnen in den früheren Entwürfen.
Ich sage soviel gleich mal zur Beruhigung, sie ist nicht mehr da.
Also soviel gleich mal vorweg.
Allerdings im Moment ist es so, dass sie sich eben wie gesagt sehr stark an
der Budapester Konvention orientiert und zwar haben wir folgendes.
Wir haben an Überwachungsmechanismen eine umgehende Sicherung von gespeicherten
Computerdaten, eine umgehende Sicherung und teilweise Weitergabe von Verkehrsdaten,
die Durchsuchung und Beschlagnahme gespeicherter Computerdaten,
die Erhebung von Verkehrsdaten in Echtzeit und die Erhebung von Inhaltsdaten in Echtzeit.
Das ist ja schon eine ganz ordentliche Liste, kann man ja wohl dazu sagen.
Das ist eine richtig ordentlich große Liste, das ist richtig.
Und man hat sich, wie ich es gesagt habe, sehr sehr orientiert daran an der
Budapester Konvention.
Da gibt es Bestimmungen, denen man diese nachempfindet. Zum Teil werden sie
auch wörtlich übernommen.
Allerdings werden zum Teil Abänderungen getroffen oder es werden neue Artikel
hinzugefügt von den Staaten, wie sie meinen, sie hätten das eine oder das andere
ganz gerne noch dabei oder konkretisiert.
Also man hat zum Beispiel bei der Durchsuchung und Beschlagnahme gespeicherte
Computerdaten, hat man jetzt auch eine Ausweitung an einem Paragraphen,
gegen den wir Sturm laufen, gemeinsam.
Der in die Richtung geht oder potenziell eine Gefahr für die Preisgabe von Verschlüsselung
und Sicherheitslücken darstellen könnte.
Also wo man tatsächlich dann auch ein Individuum das Kenntnis hat von der Funktionsweise
eines Computersystems oder eben eines Informations- oder Telekommunikationsnetzes
oder seiner Bestandteile.
Die von einem Staat angewiesen werden kann, von den Vermittlungsbehörden,
im Rahmen des zumutbaren, die erforderlichen Informationen zu liefern.
Das heißt, mitunter Verschlüsselung preiszugeben, Sicherheitslücken preiszugeben
und das alles eben im Dienste der Kriminalitätsbekämpfung und eben der Strafverfolgung.
Also das sind momentan Bestimmungen, die aufgenommen worden sind,
die so in Budapest nicht enthalten sind und die bei uns sämtliche Alarmglocken
schrillen lassen natürlich.
Aber wie gesagt, der Titel des Vertrags, eine Konvention gegen die Computerkriminalität
oder Cybercrime Convention ist ein bisschen irreführend,
weil es ist nur der erste Teil dieser Konvention ja tatsächlich mit dem Thema
unter Strafverstehen von sogenannten Cybercrimes beinhaltet.
Wenn man sich den restlichen Teil ansieht und das sind alles zusammen mehrere
Kapitel, dann hat man teilweise schon den Eindruck, sehr stark sogar den Eindruck,
dass es sich um einen Vertrag handelt, in dem ein umfassender Zugang zu Daten
geschaffen werden soll.
Vielleicht wollen wir das mal ein bisschen realweltlicher machen,
damit man eine Vorstellung bekommt, davon ausgehen würde, dass nicht jeder mit
der Budapest-Konvention so vertraut ist.
Was das praktisch bedeutet, wenn jetzt Länder wie, weiß ich nicht,
Türkei, China und eben die Länder der Europäischen Union dieser Konvention zustimmen
würden und die in dem jetzigen Zustand, also wir haben ja jetzt so einen Draft,
aber jetzt würde die so, wie sie es durchgehen würde, aber nicht bedeuten natürlich,
das hat sich jetzt ein bisschen so angehört.
Dass die eben genannten Beispiele für die zum Beispiel Überwachungsmaßnahmen
umgesetzt werden würden in den einzelnen Ländern, sondern dass man eher die Möglichkeit hat,
dass die Strafverfolger untereinander diese Daten anfordern können.
Ist das korrekt? Genau, ja.
Also ich will nur dem vorbeugen, dass man das nicht annimmt,
dass in diesem Vertrag festgehalten würde oder so, das müssen jetzt alle Länder machen,
sondern da geht es eher darum überhaupt um den Denker von Strafverfolgern,
nämlich wer wem im Rahmen vor allem der Rechtshilfe.
Welche Daten geben muss.
Ist das korrekt? Es sind natürlich Kompetenzen, die jetzt gerichtet sind an
die Strafverfolgungsbehörden, das ist schon richtig.
Nur natürlich bei einem völkerrechtlichen Vertrag, wenn der mal ratifiziert
ist, das bedeutet, wenn der dann auch völkerrechtlich die Zustimmung hat der
Staaten und entsprechend in Kraft treten kann,
dann sind die Also es sind die Staaten, die den Vertrag ratifiziert haben,
in denen er dann auch gilt, sobald er in Kraft getreten ist,
auch verpflichtet, entsprechende Maßnahmen in ihrer Gesetzgebung zu treffen,
damit der auch angewendet werden kann.
Das heißt, möglicherweise bedarf es da eben auch Gesetzesänderungen.
Aber geht das für beide Seiten? Also mal angenommen, bestimmte Überwachungsmaßnahmen
müssten dann in unterschreibenden Ländern eingeführt werden.
Geht das auch andersrum?
Müssten auch bestimmte Maßnahmen zum Schutz von bestimmten Grundrechten,
etwa bei der Kontrolle der Strafverfolgungsbehörden und so weiter,
müssten die ebenfalls umgesetzt werden? Also geht das für beide Seiten?
Ja, das ist halt das große Problem an dem Vertrag, dass wir große Defizite sehen,
was den Schutz von Grund- und Menschenrechten angeht.
Also wir haben sehr extensiv zusammen mit den Partnerorganisationen Verbesserungsvorschläge
gemacht, wiederholt gemacht, wiederholt auch in den Verhandlungsrunden.
Da gibt es die Möglichkeit auch für zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen das Wort zu ergreifen,
eben auch in diesen Verhandlungsrunden darauf hinzuweisen,
zum Teil auch mit sehr konkreten Beispielen, mit Verweisen auf aktuelle Gesetzgebung
in unterschiedlichen Ländern gegen Cybercrime und wie diese missbraucht wird,
wenn eben keine entsprechenden Safeguards da sind.
Wir sind bislang nicht gehört worden.
Also unsere Bedenken spiegeln sich nicht in dem Vertragstext wieder.
Vielleicht an der Stelle mal, um einmal ganz kurz einzuhaken,
um das so ein bisschen auseinanderzuklamüsern.
Konz hat ja gerade schon gefragt, müssen die dann auch andere Sachen umsetzen?
Wie ist das eigentlich bei so einem Treaty oder so einem Vertrag?
Was muss eigentlich alles passieren? Du hast eben auch schon so das Wort Ratifizierung benutzt.
Damit das denn in Kraft tritt, also ist das so wie so eine EU-Regulierung oder ein Directive?
Das kennen wir schon so ein bisschen.
Also wie ist das eigentlich mit so völkerrechtlichen Verträgen,
bis die in Kraft getreten sind?
Vielleicht können wir da einmal ganz kurz drauf eingehen, um dann auch zu verstehen,
warum es, also natürlich sind, ich sag mal so, Schutz von Menschenrechten in
jeder Hinsicht immer wichtig, aber ich glaube auf dieser völkerrechtlichen Ebene
wahrscheinlich sogar nochmal besonders,
weil du natürlich auch dafür sorgst, dass es einen anderen Zwang gibt,
als wenn es jetzt irgendwie nur Abkommen zwischen Einzelstaaten sind.
Vielleicht kannst du da einmal kurz drauf eingehen. Ja, also es ist tatsächlich
auch so, dass es auf UN-Ebene ganz anders läuft als auf EU-Ebene zum Beispiel.
Also wir haben hier nicht eine Kommission, einen Rat und ein Parlament und gemeinsam
erarbeiten sie einen Text und den kann man jetzt gut finden oder nicht und hat
unterschiedliche Entwürfe, sondern es ist tatsächlich so,
dass auf UN-Ebene die Staaten zusammensitzen und Verträge aushandeln.
Vielen Dank.
Und es reicht hier auch nicht unbedingt, sich anzusehen, was jetzt einzelne
Staaten, also man könnte sich dann so vorstellen, ja, da gibt es die eine Gruppe
und dann gibt es die andere Gruppe und man kann sich so ungefähr denken,
wer da in welcher für und gegen, jetzt beispielsweise Menschenrechtsschutz ist zum Beispiel.
Aber tatsächlich ist es auch sehr interessant zu sehen, wer denn die eigentlich
handelnden Personen sind, jetzt in diesem konkreten Fall, bei diesem Vertrag.
Natürlich sprechen sehr oft Botschafter und sehr oft Diplomaten,
vor allem am Anfang, wenn es jetzt um allgemeine Erklärungen geht.
Aber tatsächlich ausgehandelt werden die Vereinheiten und die rechtlichen Bestimmungen
dann von Vertretern der Strafverfolgungsbehörden.
Also das sind sehr oft Damen und Herren, die im Justizministerium der unterschiedlichen
Länder arbeiten, die sehr oft zu Beginn ihrer Karriere als Staatsanwälte tätig
waren oder eben aus den Staatsanwaltschaften kommen.
Also damit zeigt sich auch ein gewisser Mindset, der ja oft sozusagen von den
Menschen ausgeht, oder?
Und genau so ist es. Und da kann man jetzt sagen, na ja, aber trotzdem westliche
Standards und so, wenn man das so nennen möchte.
Trotz allem muss man sich auch dessen bewusst sein, dass jetzt zum Beispiel
ein Staatsanwalt, grob gesprochen bitte, aber doch andere Interessen hat,
da geht es darum, Effizienz, da geht es um Effizienz bei der Strafverfolgung, da geht es darum,
Straftaten aufzudecken und ein Staatsanwalt wird tendenziell immer mehr Tools
haben wollen als weniger, klarerweise.
Das ist auch oft, ja, ich weiß nicht, Verpflichtungen, gewisse Quoten zu erfüllen,
geschuldet und natürlich, ja, man sieht hier allein schon das Mindset,
wie du richtig gesagt hast, das da dahinter steht.
Natürlich sind jetzt auch Staatsanwälte den Menschenrechten verpflichtet.
Also wir sind jetzt in Europa zum Beispiel, alle Staaten Mitglieder da,
also alle haben so Mitglieder im Europarat und wir haben alle die Europäische
Konvention für Menschenrechte ratifiziert.
Also es ist anwendbar in Europa zum Beispiel. Aber dennoch, also das muss man
ja vielleicht dann global betrachten, nicht wahr?
Also ein Staatsanwalt in Iran würde sicherlich nicht nicht unbedingt in diese
Kategorie fallen, nicht wahr?
Genau so ist es. Man sieht es aber auch mit europäischen Staatsanwälten zum Beispiel.
Die meinen, das passt ja und die Menschenrechte gelten ja sowieso und schauen
wir, dass wir da jetzt gute Tools bekommen.
Also man hört das jetzt ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert, aber das ist durchaus
nicht unüblich zu hören.
Also die meinen, manche Staaten, die sich da jetzt besonders laut machen oder besonders laut sind,
für mehr Schutz von Menschenrechten oder für konkretere Safeguards gegenüber
überbordenden Überwachungsmaßnahmen. Das ist einfach Panikmache.
Also man hört das. Man hört das durchaus auch aus den westlichen,
von westlichen Staaten.
Man hört zum Beispiel auch von den USA die meinen, ah, well,
privacy, that's just another human right.
Also man hört diese Dinge.
Natürlich Natürlich muss man dazu sagen, klarerweise, wenn man jetzt den Kontext,
das Umfeld von gewissen Staaten politisch gesehen,
rechtlich gesehen jetzt auch mitdenkt, dann kann man ungefähr einteilen,
wer wo steht und wie die Meinung ist,
aber dennoch, und das ist ganz wichtig bei diesem Vertrag auch mitzudenken,
es geht darum, dass vor allem Leute aus den Strafverfolgungsbehörden hier diesen
Vertrag in den Details verhandeln.
Und zu der Frage noch, wie das denn funktioniert mit der Rechtsetzung allgemein auf UN-Ebene.
Also es ist so, dass die Staaten einen Vertragstext hier aushandeln in den unterschiedlichsten
Runden, wie wir das hier jetzt gerade erleben.
Und im konkreten Fall war es
so, dass wir im Sommer den ersten sogenannten Zero Draft bekommen haben.
Zero Draft ist ein Vertragstext, von dem man ausgeht, dass die Bestimmungen,
die darin enthalten sind, mehrheitsfähig sind.
Also das wird daraus abgeleitet,
wie die einzelnen Verhandlungspositionen der Staaten sich dargestellt haben
in den Verhandlungsrunden davor,
welche Unterstützungen für welche Bestimmungen sie gegeben haben,
gibt es da eine Mehrheit für die eine oder andere Sichtweise und kann man davon
ausgehen, dass eine bestimmte Regelung, jetzt Konsens, ja Konsens wäre wünschenswert
aus Sicht der Verhandlerin,
also der Vorsitzenden, aber doch mehrheitsfähig ist.
Dieser Zero-Draft ist jetzt gerade in der letzten Verhandlungssonde auch in
New York im Sommer wäre das Ziel gewesen,
Bestimmung für Bestimmung durchzugehen und sich anzusehen, kann man die vorläufig
schon einmal aus der Diskussion stellen.
Also sind die Staaten damit soweit zufrieden, dass sie sagen,
sie haben keine Gegenvorschläge und
sie würden jetzt auch keine weiteren Abänderungen oder Zusätze wünschen.
Das war leider nicht der Fall. Das Ziel des Vertrags ist ja nach wie vor,
dass man sagt, man bekommt einen Vertragstext zustande, von dem man ausgehen kann,
dass man ihn in der nächsten Verhandlungsrunde, jetzt am Ende Jänner,
Anfang Februar, die siebte Verhandlungsrunde und laut Verhandlungsplan auch die letzte,
das ist ein sehr, sehr sportliches Vorhaben, dass man den Vertragstext soweit
bekommt, dass die Staaten dem tatsächlich auch zustimmen können.
Und gewollt ist eine Annahme des Vertragstextes im Konsens.
Das sieht aus heutiger Sicht sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich aus.
Also es gibt dermaßen tiefe Gräben und starke Spaltungen auch,
gerade zu grundlegenden Themen und da sind wir bei dem Thema wie,
was ist denn eigentlich ein Cybercrime?
Aber was ist denn eigentlich ein Cybercrime?
Ich finde das eine ganz gute Frage, um das ja jetzt mal kurz so einzuwerfen,
damit die Hörerinnen so ein bisschen so ein Gefühl haben.
Was steht denn auf der Wunschliste, was ist denn eigentlich ein Cybercrime?
Ja, vielleicht würde ich es sogar noch erweitern. Also vielleicht können sich
noch Hörer was vorstellen unter Cybercrime, aber vor allen Dingen, wo ist die Abgrenzung?
Also was wird denn nicht sozusagen mit, naja, digitalen oder Kommunikationstechnologien mehr verbunden?
Also ich glaube, gar nicht mal so der Kern zum Stritten, sondern eher die Retter, oder?
Ja, es ist ein bisschen die Frage, wie gesagt, es gibt keinen internationalen Konsens darüber.
Es gibt, und ich beziehe mich jetzt wieder vor allem auf die Budapester-Konvention,
ein Set an Bestimmungen, ein Set an Straftatbeständen, die darin aufgenommen sind.
Und wir unterscheiden darin sehr stark zwischen sogenannten Cyberdependent Crimes
und Cyber-Enabled Crimes.
Und du hast das vorher schon angesprochen, du hast gesagt, naja,
aber so ziemlich jede Straftat kann jetzt mit Hilfe von Computern und digitalen
Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
Das ist richtig, aber genau darum geht es. Wo sind die Ränder?
Wir haben zum einen jetzt diese Cyberdependent Crimes, auf die wir ganz besonders abstellen.
Wir sind der Meinung, mit mir meine ich Epicenter Works und auch die anderen
Organisationen, mit denen wir kooperieren, dass ausschließlich Cyberdependent Crimes,
also solche Strafhandlungen im Vertrag aufgenommen werden sollen,
die zum Zum einen ein Computersystem als Ziel haben, also auf dessen Schädigung
zum Beispiel abstellen oder die ohne ein solches überhaupt nicht durchführbar wären.
Wohingegen Cyber-enabled Crimes wären jetzt Strafhandlungen,
alle anderen Straftatbestände zum Beispiel, die halt nur mit Hilfe eines Computers durchgeführt werden.
Da ist ein Computersystem beispielsweise lediglich ein Hilfsmittel.
Aber es ist gut möglich, diese Straftat auch durchzuführen ohne.
Also Betrug zum Beispiel.
Für den Betrug muss ich nicht zwangsläufig ein Computersystem verwenden.
Anders sieht es hingegen aus, wenn ich jetzt sage, ja, ein rechtswidriger Zugang
zu einem Computersystem, also klassisch Hacking, Ja, da brauche ich es.
Da ist ein Computersystem sogar das Zielobjekt.
Das bedeutet, würdet ihr euch damit durchsetzen können? Also mit der Idee nur cyberdependent?
Nein, das ist schwierig. Wir haben wiederholt dafür argumentiert,
zu sagen, jetzt rechtswidriger Zugang zu Computersystem, rechtswidriges Abfangen
von diversen über Computer-Daten-Übermittlungen,
einen Eingriff in Computer-Daten, der Eingriff zum Beispiel in ein Computersystem,
und auch der Missbrauch von Devices, von Vorrichtungen.
Das wären so diese Core Cyber Dependent Crimes.
Also der Kernbestand, wo wir sagen, nur der sollte geregelt werden in einer
Cybercrime Convention.
Jetzt ist es aber so, dass.
Dass man sich nicht darauf einigen konnte, einige Cyber-enabled-Crimes herauszunehmen.
Und das liegt daran, dass sie auch in Budapest enthalten sind,
in der Budapester Konvention.
Und das eine ist eine computerbezogene Fälschung und das andere ist ein computerbezogener Betrug.
Der computerbezogene Betrug. Man hat dann diese auch ein bisschen abgeändert.
Man hat dann einige, jetzt gerade im aktuellen Draft, einige beunruhigende Ergänzungen hinzugefügt.
Was wir auch dazu haben, das muss ich vielleicht auch sagen,
sind Straftatbestände, die so aus dem, wie soll ich sagen, die Staaten haben
es am Anfang Kindepornografie genannt, also Kindesmissbrauchsmaterial,
genauso wie jetzt Cybergrooming oder das nicht non-consensual dissemination
of intimate images zum Beispiel.
Also diese Straftatbestände werden sehr wahrscheinlich Teil der Konvention bleiben.
Wir möchten jetzt keinesfalls so verstanden werden, dass wir sagen,
das sind keine wichtigen Verbrechen, die hier geahndet werden sollen.
Im Gegenteil. Also es ist sehr, sehr wichtig, gegen Kindesmissbrauch vorzugehen, auch online.
Wir fragen uns halt nur, ob diese Konvention der richtige Rahmen dafür ist.
Also nur für mich so, bei Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellungen geht bei mir natürlich
immer gleich die Chatkontrolle-Glocke an.
Ist es denn so, bei diesen Cybercrime-Definitionen, dass sie dann auch unmittelbar
oder mittelbar mit entsprechenden.
Dass Werkzeugen, also Ermittlungswerkzeugen für Strafverfolgungsbehörden verknüpft
sind, also dass es sozusagen gerade
wenn es um die Verbreitung von Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellungen, ETC geht,
dass das dann auch mit bestimmten Überwachungsmaßnahmen einhergibt oder gibt
es da keine unmittelbare Verknüpfung?
Die Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die durch die Konvention quasi genehmigt sind,
sind ja die, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe.
Also die durchaus stark eingreifend sind. Die sind jetzt aber nicht speziell
nur auf den Kindesmissbrauch betrimmt und ausgelegt.
Also die sollen gelten für sämtliche, gerade bei den Überwachungsmechanismen
sollte man vielleicht dazu sagen, bei sämtlichen Kapiteln, wo es darum geht
zu überwachen und international Rechtshilfe zu leisten und zusammenzuarbeiten,
geht man ja darüber hinaus über diese Straftatbestände, die in der Konvention normiert werden.
Also diese weitreichenden Eingriffe, Überwachungsmaßnahmen und dann eben auch
die internationale Kooperation,
also der Austausch von Daten, die durch diese Überwachungsmechanismen gewonnen
werden, sollen anwendbar sein auf jedwede strafrechtliche Handlungen,
wo ein Computersystem verwendet wurde.
Und das sind noch einmal eine ganze Menge weiterer Straftaten,
wenn man darüber nachdenkt.
Also man hat jetzt für Kindesmissbrauchdarstellungen keine ganz spezifischen,
keine besonderen in dem spezifischen Paragrafen festgelegten Ahndungsmechanismen, das nicht.
Was man allerdings schon hat und das gibt uns momentan sehr großen Grund zur Unruhe,
ist ein, so wie wir es lesen, mögliches
Verbot von konsensual produzierten Sexting-Materialien unter Jugendlichen.
Das ist ja auch in Deutschland in der Gesetzgebung eher problematisch.
Weiß ich nicht, wie es in Österreich ist, aber hier wird ja gerade der Straftatbestand
versucht wieder zu ändern, weil es eine große Kriminalisierung von Kindern gibt und Jugendlichen.
Ja, wir haben auch das Problem, dass, wenn man sich die Statistiken ansieht
in Österreich, sehr häufig Jugendliche tatsächlich auch strafrechtlich verfolgt
werden, einfach aufgrund von Sexting, sage ich jetzt mal.
Also einfach dem Übermitteln von Darstellungen, die aber konsensual angefertigt
wurden. Jetzt ist es schon richtig, dass es natürlich in einer globalen Konvention
auch kulturelle Unterschiede gibt.
Wir sehen allerdings ein allgemeines Verbot hier wirklich sehr, sehr kritisch.
Also jetzt hast du diese Beispiele genannt, aber das ist ja von Anfang an, gibt es ja mehr davon.
Also du hast jetzt hier relativ spezifisch erzählt, was ist denn mit diesen
Fragen, Desinformation sollte drin sein, Hate Speech sollte drin sein,
Urheberrecht sollte drin sein. Oder auch der Begriff des Terrorismus,
da ist ja einfach eine ganze Menge.
Wie kann man sich darüber informieren,
wie der Stand bei den einzelnen kritischen Fragen eigentlich ist?
Schafft man das, wenn man jetzt nicht daran so aktuell teilnimmt wie du?
Das ist ein guter Punkt. Diese möglichen Straftatbestände, die du jetzt gerade
angesprochen hast, das ist das, was ich vorher den Wunschbrief ans Christkind genannt habe.
Die Staaten haben sich am Anfang genau das gewünscht, was sie gemeint haben,
was wollen wir jetzt unbedingt. Also wir wollen unter dem Deckmantel der Terrorismusbekämpfung
Oppositionelle quasi mit dem Segen der UN am besten vielleicht auch noch zum Schweigen bringen.
Sind ja schließlich alle Cybercriminals. Nein, es war so, am Anfang wurde es
wahnsinnig aufgeblasen.
Also so in den ersten vier Verhandlungsrunden und wir sind erst im vergangenen
Jahr, im vergangenen Winter eingestiegen in das Prozedere. Also da ging es gerade
um die vierte Verhandlungsrunde.
In Wien war die damals und als wir den Text, als ich mir den Text das erste
Mal angeschaut habe, ich habe geglaubt, ich traue meinen Augen nicht.
Wir hatten tatsächlich hier drinnen.
Diverse, vage, schwammige Formulierungen zu terrorismusbezogenen Straftaten.
Jetzt gibt es nicht mal eine international anerkannte Definition von,
was ist denn Terrorismus rechtlich verbindlich?
Was soll denn dann bitte schon rechtlich verbindlich sein, eine terrorismusbezogene
Straftat? Was ist Subversion?
Was ist Extremismus? Das ist rechtlich nicht definiert.
Und das ist ein ganz großes Problem, dass wir, ich muss dazu sagen,
diese ganzen Straftatbestände haben es nicht geschafft in den sogenannten Zero Draft.
Also es wurde dann auch aufgenommen, sowas wie Blasphemie. Pakistan hat sich
Blasphemie gewünscht. Oh yeah.
Ja, es ging halt alles um Beleidigung des Propheten. Also wir hatten das ganze Spektrum.
Wir hatten hier wirklich alles Mögliche drinnen.
Die Staaten haben es gebracht. Ich denke halt auch natürlich zum Teil,
weil sie es national verkaufen mussten. Also wir wollen das.
Wir haben uns dafür eingesetzt. Also ich denke, jede Stadt muss dann national
natürlich auch Rechenschaft ablegen.
Was haben wir dann versucht zu bekommen? Wie haben wir uns dafür eingesetzt?
Und genau diese vielen kritischen inhaltsbezogenen Straftatbestände,
die vorgeschlagen wurden und die vor allem auch bei, also nicht nur,
aber auch bei befreundeten Journalisten und Pressefreiheitsorganisationen,
die Alarmglocken unheimlich laut schrillen haben lassen.
All die haben es nicht geschafft in den Zero Draft. Warum nicht?
Weil es ja so ist, man kann sich zunächst mal was wünschen, aber dann liegt
es an den Staaten auch zu sagen, was können wir unterstützen und was nicht.
Und wir haben die gesamte Session im April damit verbracht zuzuhören,
was Staaten bereit sind mitzutragen und was nicht.
Und dann war relativ bald klar, dass es diese weitreichenden Bestimmungen in
dieser Form, wie sie gewünscht sind, nicht geben wird im Zero Draft.
Worauf man sich allerdings geeinigt hat, ist ein, ja es ist bekannt als der
Artikel 17, so ist er momentan, es ist Artikel 17, noch immer im Draft.
Und Artikel 17 nimmt Bezug auf Straftatbestände, die in anderen internationalen
Verträgen, es bezieht sich nur auf internationale Verträge.
Enthalten sind und die dann mit Hilfe eines Computerprogramms,
eines Computersystems durchgeführt werden.
Die sollen nicht ausgeschlossen werden vom Anwendungsbereich.
Und das Problem ist halt für uns jetzt, dass wir sagen, naja,
aber internationale Konventionen, was bedeutet das denn? Internationale Verträge
können das dann auch regionale sein?
Es ist zu wenig klar. Klar, das könnte dann halt auch durch die Hintertür ein
Einfallstor sein für schwammige Terrorismusbegriffe zum Beispiel.
Jetzt ist momentan so ein bisschen die Diskussion entbrannt,
also ein bisschen ist jetzt untertrieben sehr heftig, man möge den Begriff austauschen
und sagen UN-Konventionen.
Damit ist zumindest mal klar und ein Referenzrahmen geschaffen,
dass nur diese Straftatbestände herangezogen werden dürfen, die in der UN,
in einem UN-Dokument anerkannt sind.
Und das wird schon mal erheblich einschränken.
Genau, so ist es zunächst einmal zu sehen. Wie kann man sich darüber informieren,
was drinnen ist? Ja, es ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Es gibt eine Webseite von diesem Ad-Hoc-Committee, also das AHC,
wie wir es nennen, das ist das Ad-Hoc-Committee, das zuständig ist für diese Verhandlungen.
Also es ist die algerische Botschafterin, wurde gewählt zur Vorsitzenden und
sie zusammen mit ihrem Team leiten diese Verhandlungen und sind auch maßgeblich
in der Ausarbeitung der jeweiligen Drafts beteiligt.
Wenn man sich das ansieht, auf der Webseite wird regelmäßig ein Update gepostet
zu den jeweiligen Verhandlungsrunden und dann auch die Dokumente, die jeweiligen.
Also im Moment sieht man bei der siebten Verhandlungsrunde in einem PDF-Dokument
den aktuellen Vertragstext. Wenn die Verhandlungen dann wieder losgehen,
im Jänner, im Februar, wird es täglich updated und dann hat man auch Redlines dabei.
Also dann sieht man noch sehr genau, wo der Vertrag abgeändert wurde,
welche Staaten wofür plädieren.
Also man kann sich das tagtäglich dann ansehen, ohne sich jetzt stundenlang
vor den Livestream des UN-Fernsehens setzen zu müssen. Ich gebe zu,
es ist nicht unbedingt prickelnd.
Ich habe es getan, testweise, weil wir ja schon eine Weile den Termin heute
abgemacht haben und ich habe dann einfach manchmal eine Stunde mir von diesem
UN-Fernsehen angesehen, aber das bringt einem natürlich nichts,
wenn man strukturiert daran gehen will. Genau, also es ist schwierig.
Ich muss auch dazu sagen, ich habe mir gerade in New York den einen Nachmittag
tatsächlich auch im ON-Streaming angeschaut und das war unheimlich anstrengend.
Ich muss dazu sagen, wir sitzen diese ganzen Verhandlungen durch und das macht
einen großen Unterschied, ob man tatsächlich im Raum ist und das live miterlebt
oder ob man sich es dann danach im Webstream anschaut. Aber ihr seid ja dann
auch so ein bisschen als beteiligte Partei dabei. Nein.
Ja, also da kannst du vielleicht gleich noch drauf eingehen, wie das denn ist.
Aber ich habe das so in Erinnerung, als wir im Frühjahr auch in New York waren, dass das ja,
also wahrscheinlich ist es bei den Verhandlungen selber nochmal ein bisschen
was anderes, aber dass es ja voll häufig nur so Statement-mäßige Willensbekundungen
sind und keine wirklichen Diskussionen stattfinden.
Ist das in diesen Verhandlungen auch so oder ist das ein bisschen anders,
als wir das da erlebt haben?
Ja und nein. Also zum einen nochmal nur ganz kurz, es verhandeln ja die Staaten,
wir verhandeln da ja nicht mit.
Es ist bei diesen Verhandlungen zum Glück so, dass sich das Komitee darauf geeinigt
hat, diese Verhandlungen so offen und zugänglich zu machen wie nur möglich und
eben auch der Zivilgesellschaft den Zugang zu ermöglichen.
Wir sitzen hinten im Raum auf eigens designierten Plätzen und bekommen zu den
jeweiligen Kapiteln dann immer ein Rederecht von drei Minuten.
Das ist nicht sehr viel, das heißt Arbeitsteilung ist da immer so das Gebot
der Stunde, um wirklich alle Punkte, die wir gerne durchbringen wollen,
auch gesagt zu haben. Oder?
Ja, im Großen und Ganzen. Es ist nicht immer ganz einfach.
Bei den Staaten selbst funktioniert es so, dass, ich weiß nicht,
man bespricht jetzt die Clients und dann wird der Vertragstext,
so wie er vorgeschlagen ist, das ist tatsächlich in einem großen Word-Dokument an die Wand gebeamt.
Und dann wird in diesem riesengroßen Wortdokument mit Redlines dazu geschrieben, was jeder Staat denkt.
Und das wird so dazu geschrieben, dass man sagt, unterstützt oder unterstützt nicht.
Dann gibt es dann das Kürzel für jeden Staat, dass da jeweils dazu geschrieben
wird, ob unterstützt oder eben nicht oder ob alternative Vorschläge gemacht werden.
Also jetzt ganz konkret, Juristen können ewig lang über Worte streiten,
aber ganz konkret jetzt über Formulierungen eben, welche Formulierung bevorzugt
wird von, ich weiß nicht, Deutschland oder Österreich oder Japan oder sonstigen Staaten.
Und dann ist wieder die Frage, kann das eine Mehrheit finden oder nicht?
Das ist schon sehr, das fühlt sich schon sehr, wie soll man sagen,
das ist schon sehr abstrus, wenn man sich das so vorstellt.
Das ist vor allen Dingen etwas zähnig, denn man muss sich ja vorstellen,
die Weltgemeinschaft ist ja deutlich größer als die EU und wenn dann alle mal was sagen, dauert es.
Aber ich würde gerne nochmal auf euch zurück, also auf die NGOs.
Denn wer möchte, kann sich diese langwierigen UN-Web-TV-Sessions ja mal ansehen.
Da braucht man nur zehn Minuten gucken, dann hat man eine Idee.
Aber zu euren drei Minuten würde ich gerne noch was wissen.
Also neben Human Rights Watch ist dabei und Open Access und die IFF.
Man kann sich auch eine Liste runterholen, da ist die UN ja relativ transparent.
Aber da sitzt natürlich auch Interpol oder Microsoft. Haben die denn auch drei Minuten? Ja.
Genau. Das betrifft alle Multi-Stakeholders.
Und Multi-Stakeholders wird da weit gefasst. Das können sein eben NGOs,
das kann aber auch sein Microsoft und das kann auch sein Google,
die sind auch sehr, sehr, sehr vertreten oder die Internationale Handelskammer.
Das sind alles, wir fallen alle unter den Begriff Multi-Stakeholders.
Wir sitzen alle hinten und wir haben alle drei Minuten Rede reicht.
Warum müsst ihr danach immer gleich verschwinden? Also mehrmals ist dort angegeben
worden, dass die Modiste Ecole das Gebäude verlassen sollen und zwar pronto. Warum?
Ah, nein. Aha, ich weiß schon. Das war die New York Session, oder? Die letzte.
Ich habe mehrere geguckt, aber wurde mir auch mehrfach angesagt.
Nein, nein, wir müssen das Gebäude nicht verlassen. Wir können da dabei sein.
Sondern es ging bloß darum, dass an den, und ich glaube, ich weiß,
worauf du dich beziehst,
an den Tagen es so war, dass wir, ja, die New York Session hat die Grausamkeiten,
die ich vorhin beschrieben habe, die Wunschliste wieder eingeführt in den Vertrag.
Also da hat man dann wieder den Brief ins Christkind geschrieben im Sommer.
Und dementsprechend haben sich die Verhandlungen verzögert. Das heißt,
man war komplett behind schedule.
Man hat absolut nicht das Ziel, das soll erfüllt, was man sich eigentlich gesetzt
hat. Und die Vorsitzende hat dann gemeint, okay, so geht es nicht weiter,
wir müssen dieses und jenes noch abarbeiten und schaffen, wir haben kommende
Woche an jenen Tagen eine Nachtsession dazu.
Das heißt, wir haben dann noch von sieben bis zehn Uhr abends eine extra drei
Stunden Session und dann war halt so ein bisschen die Frage,
wer darf denn da noch dabei sein. Es ist halt auch so, dass die Zugangskarten
dann zeitliche Limits haben.
Bei unseren Zugangskarten ging es konkret darum, dass sie nicht wie in Wien
eben diese ganz normalen Karten zum Swipen und man ist durch die Kontrolle durch
sind, sondern in New York kriegt man das tatsächlich auf Papier ausgedruckt.
Das ist so überhaupt nicht fälschungssicher.
Und muss sich dann ausweisen beim Hineingehen jedes Mal bei den Security Guards.
Jetzt ist die Sache halt die, dass beim Konferenzgebäude, also beim Teil des
UN-Gebäudes in New York, wo die Konferenzsäle sind, die Security Guards dann
einfach irgendwann nicht mehr da sind, weil halt, ja, Feierabend.
Und dann war so am Anfang ein bisschen die Frage, naja, was macht man jetzt
mit den Multi-Stakeholders? das.
Die können ja dann gar nicht dabei sein und wir haben das dann auch angesprochen
und es wurde uns zugesichert, wir könnten dabei sein.
Es gibt noch einen Eingang, wo Security Guards wären, wo wir hinein könnten,
wo wir dann auch wieder in die Verhandlungssäle könnten.
Also nein, wir mussten, kurz gesagt, wir mussten das Gebäude nicht verlassen,
wir durften dabei sein. Wir haben das auch gemacht.
Für diejenigen, die es dann noch ausgehalten haben, weil von 10 in der Früh
bis Bis 10 Uhr abends ist es halt wirklich trotz Pausen dann schon einigermaßen anstrengend.
Aber ja, wir haben drei Minuten und diese drei Minuten werden sehr rigoros auch
überwacht und die werden sehr rigoros auch eingehalten.
Genau, das ist halt wirklich schwierig, dass man all die Punkte durchbringt,
die man eigentlich sagen möchte.
Also ich glaube, es geht jetzt so ein bisschen auch heraus aus meinen Erzählungen,
hoffe ich, wie groß die Baustellen hier sind, wie unsicher eigentlich,
also wie unglaublich offen dieser Vertrag noch ist und wie viel Unsicherheit
er eigentlich mit sich bringt im aktuellen Stadium noch immer.
Drei Minuten sind hier wirklich ein Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein.
Deswegen, ich habe schon gesagt, Arbeitsteilung ist so ein bisschen das Gebot der Stunde.
Wir koordinieren uns dann immer mit den anderen Organisationen und schauen,
wer deckt welchen Teil denn eigentlich ab, wer spricht wozu und wo ist es nötig,
dass wir uns wiederholen, damit es auch wirklich gehört wird.
Wir haben auch zusätzlich dann die Möglichkeit natürlich, dass wir schriftliche
Stellungnahmen dem Sekretariat zukommen lassen.
Es werden die Wortmeldungen dann auch, wenn man das möchte, verschriftlicht
auf der Website veröffentlicht.
Genau, also das ist so wirklich die Möglichkeit, die wir haben,
in den Verhandlungen selbst.
Ich sollte vielleicht, und das ist ganz wichtig, auch noch dazu sagen,
es gibt diese sogenannten Informals, also das sind so informelle Verhandlungsgruppen,
die wurden mit der vierten Verhandlungsrunde in Wien eingeführt und die befassen sich damit,
dass sie eben genau diese Teile des Vertrags abdecken, die total kontrovers sind.
Also als wir noch die Wunschliste hatten, den Terrorismus und den Extremismus
und weiß der Kuckuck was noch an Grausamkeiten,
hat die Vorsitzende gemeint, okay, es hat keinen Zweck, diese Punkte sind so
kontrovers, das hat keinen Zweck, das im Plenum weiter zu diskutieren,
weil das hält die weitere Arbeit auf.
Wir lagern das aus in diese informellen Verhandlungsgruppen.
Da gab es dann mehrere, auch zur Terminologie, auch zum Anwendungsbereich,
auch zu den Fragen der Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellungen, zu unterschiedlichsten
Themengebieten gab es verschiedenste Gruppen.
Und die haben parallel dazu immer für ein paar Stunden am Tag verhandelt und
man hat da versucht Konsens zu finden.
Die Krux für uns an der Sache ist allerdings, dass wir zu diesen informellen
Verhandlungsrunden keinen Zutritt haben.
Also es geht gar nicht darum, dass wir da Rederecht haben, sondern wir können
de facto nicht dort im Raum dabei sein. Gibt es ein Protokoll?
Nein, weil wir, weil natürlich da wirklich, also da wird halt wirklich das Fleisch
diskutiert. Also da geht es halt dann wirklich um die Wurst.
Was es schon gab in der vierten Runde war, dass die,
es hat jede Gruppe natürlich auch ein, zwei Verhandlungsteilnehmer als Leiter so quasi,
die versuchen sollten auf einen Konsens hinzuarbeiten und die haben damals natürlich
auch Goodwill gezeigt am Anfang und Meetings mit der Zivilgesellschaft oder
mit den Multi-Stakeholders einberufen.
Das heißt, wir hatten dann oft Calls oder ich glaube wir hatten fast nur Calls,
wir Wir hatten gar keine Führung.
Doch, mitunter, glaube ich, ein, zwei, ich erinnere mich jetzt gar nicht genau,
physische Treffen, wo man sich dann ausgetauscht hat.
Also wo man erfahren hat, wenn man Glück hatte, wie denn der Stand der Dinge
ist, ohne jetzt großartig die Details zu hören, wer jetzt was sagt.
Also ich meine, man hat es sich ungefähr denken können, aber so ein bisschen
den Status Quo zu erfahren.
Hauptsächlich ging es den Verhandlungsleitern aber darum zu erfahren,
was wir denken und ob wir konkret das Wording vorschlagen können für die eine
oder andere Bestimmung.
Ich würde dich eigentlich nochmal, also du hast ganz am Anfang mal gesagt,
dass du auf Deutsch kaum über diese ganzen Verhandlungen zur Konvention gesprochen hast.
Also wenn, also ich denke jetzt, du hast ein bisschen geschädert,
weil so die Knackpunkte sind und den Prozess, würdest du dir das manchmal wünschen
oder ist es auch so, dass du dir vorstellen könntest,
es würde auch stören, wenn jetzt plötzlich auf bestimmte Aspekte in den Verhandlungen
sich eine große Öffentlichkeit stürzen würde.
Also könntest du da eine Meinung zu sagen?
Was jetzt zu der Frage, ob man mehr Öffentlichkeitswirksamkeit brauchen sollte
für gewisse Punkte? Du hast eben erklärt, diese informellen Gespräche,
die haben kein Protokoll, denn da geht es ums Fleisch.
Und wir haben ja nur bei vielen Verhandlungen, wird Kaledi sicherlich auch sagen
können, gerade so bei der Chatkontrolle gesehen, plötzlich dringt da eine Öffentlichkeit ein.
Da wird es interessant, aber auch skandalisiert teilweise. Also würdest du dir
das manchmal eher wünschen?
Oder glaubst du, das ist vielleicht auch ganz cool, dass diese ganzen Verhandlungen,
nicht nur informellen, sondern auch die Ad-hoc-Committees, Sessions,
wie sie stattfinden, eigentlich unter dem Radar der Öffentlichkeit sind.
Also was hat Vor- und Nachteile für dich?
Ich würde mir wünschen, natürlich zu diesen Informations auch Zutritt zu haben.
Also ich denke, dass je öffentlicher, umso besser.
Man muss dazu sagen, die Verhandlungen, so wie sie jetzt sind,
werden immer wieder von anderen Organisationen, die häufiger auf UN-Ebene tätig
sind, als Gold Standard bezeichnet.
Weil es absolut nicht üblich ist, bei
der UN dann auch tatsächlich die Zivilgesellschaft eingebunden zu haben.
Also dementsprechend, wir sind uns absolut bewusst, dass das schon mal ein großer
Schritt ist, so wie es jetzt ist.
Nichtsdestotrotz natürlich, Öffentlichkeit und Zugang zu den Informationen betreffend
die informellen Gruppen sind wirklich wichtig.
In Wahrheit bekommt man den halt nur dann, wenn man sich mit Staatenvertretern
bei einem Café, sag ich mal, in der Pause unterhält und mal nachfragt.
Beziehungsweise wenn es eben diese Informationsrunden gibt. Und die waren jetzt,
in New York hatten wir genau eine und die hat uns im Nachhinein,
dann wurden wir informiert, wie jetzt der Stand der Dinge war.
Und von den anderen Gruppen erfährt man dann am Schluss im Plenum,
was da ausgehandelt wurde, aber man hat keine Ahnung, wie und was und wer.
Im Allgemeinen muss ich schon dazu sagen, ich würde mir für den gesamten Verhandlungsprozess
sehr viel mehr Öffentlichkeitswirksamkeit wünschen.
Ich glaube, es ist sehr wichtig, auch für die breite Öffentlichkeit,
sich dessen bewusst zu sein, dass diese Verhandlungen gerade laufen,
dass diese möglicherweise jetzt im Winter zu einem Abschluss kommen werden,
auch wenn das möglicherweise jetzt sehr, sehr optimistisch gedacht ist. Man weiß es nicht.
Und dass es tatsächlich Auswirkungen haben kann. Und vor allem auch,
sage ich jetzt mal an alle Journalisten, die vielleicht hier zuhören,
das kann auch Meinungsfreiheitsfragen betreffen.
Und zwar sehr leicht. Also ich habe schon gesagt, es gibt hier Öffnungsklauseln,
es gibt mitunter, also es werden vermutlich Straftatbestände eingeführt werden,
die schon auch das Potenzial haben,
hier die Arbeit von Journalisten zu erschweren.
Und man muss sich auch bewusst sein, dass das auch die schwammige Formulierung
der aktuellen Core Cybercrimes sind.
Das Potenzial haben, auch Good Faith Hackers, Journalisten,
Aktivisten und so weiter einzubeziehen, deren Arbeit wirklich schwieriger zu
machen und sie potenziell auch in der Strafverfolgungsgefahr aussetzen.
Also mir wäre es sehr recht, natürlich seitens der UN mehr öffentlichen Zugang
zu haben, nämlich auch zu den Informals, aber umgekehrt eben auch ist es wichtig,
das Interesse und auch das Bewusstsein in der Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen,
um diese Verhandlungen auch entsprechend zu verfolgen, egal wie anstrengend
jetzt vielleicht das UN Web TV sein kann, aber es steht hier viel am Spiel.
Vielleicht, um nochmal bei der Frage von Kranz so ein bisschen einzuhaken.
Du hast jetzt gesagt, du hättest da gerne mehr Aufmerksamkeit.
Wie ist es denn, ich sag mal, mit öffentlichkeitswirksamer, also wirksamen Aktionen?
Und weitestgehend sitzen ja in der UN und auch in diesen Verhandlungen wahrscheinlich
einfach Diplomaten, das sind Staatsbeamten.
Wie würde denn so eine zivilgesellschaftliche Aufmerksamkeit,
wie wir sie teilweise in der EU haben, überhaupt aussehen? Was ist da eigentlich effektiv?
Also wir haben ja irgendwie schon ein paar offene Briefe und sowas gesehen,
aber ich finde es immer interessant. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen das,
was wir hier versuchen, den Hörerinnen mitzugeben.
Wann macht es eigentlich Sinn, mich als Bürgerin in diesen Policy-Prozess einzubringen
und wann ist es sinnvoll, da auch irgendwie reinzugrätschen und was muss ich da eigentlich tun?
Und das würde mich bei der UN tatsächlich interessieren, einfach weil es ja
am Ende schon die Mitgliedstaaten sind, die da entscheiden und das wahrscheinlich
auch irgendwie ein Stück weit von oben von der Bundesregierung kommt.
Genau, das ist es. Also ich habe jetzt nicht meine Abgeordneten,
die ich gewählt habe, für das EU-Parlament zum Beispiel direkt.
Also ich habe hier kein Pendant auf UN-Ebene.
Es stimmt, es sind Diplomaten bzw.
Ministerienmitarbeiter, es sind Beamte, die hier handeln.
Der Zugang, den wir bekommen jetzt als Zivilgesellschaft zu diesen Verhandlungen,
ist wie gesagt offenbar die Ausnahme.
Also es ist für uns das erste Mal, dass wir auf UN-Ebene tätig sind,
aber was ich von anderen Organisationen, die das regelmäßig machen,
höre, ist, dass es wirklich Goldstandard ist.
Also von dem her, ja, schon mal ein erster Schritt, aber natürlich mediale Aufmerksamkeit,
wir haben das versucht wiederholt herzustellen.
Also wir hatten eine Pressekonferenz in Wien, ich habe dann,
also eine physische in Wien, die dann auch, sie war physisch und online,
ich habe dann auch eine virtuelle moderiert für den spanischsprachigen Bereich,
eben mit Partnerorganisationen hier,
als sie hier waren, eben aus den lateinamerikanischen Ländern.
Kolleginnen hatten auch in der letzten Session bei der UN haben sie eine Pressekonferenz
gehalten, aber ich selbst nicht am Panel,
aber da gab es in Kooperation mit dem US Press Service ein sehr gutes und auch
sehr gut rezipiertes Pressegespräch.
Diese Dinge haben gut funktioniert und laufen erstmal.
Wir sind momentan auch dabei, auf verschiedensten Ländern, auf verschiedensten
Ebenen auch Artikel-Operates zu schreiben.
Bei mir steht das noch vor Weihnachten an auch. Wir versuchen über Blogposts zu informieren.
Die Medienarbeit ist da natürlich sehr wichtig.
Es ist wie gesagt schwierig für den Einzelnen, sich hier einzusetzen,
weil man jetzt nicht die Möglichkeit hat, direkt mit Abgeordneten oder mit Parteien
oder sonst was in Kontakt zu treten.
Es sind wie gesagt Staatsvertreter, es sind die Regierungen,
es sind Diplomaten, die hier handeln.
Nichtsdestotrotz wäre es möglicherweise auch eine Idee, sich hier an die Behörden
in den eigenen Staaten zu wenden.
Und dann wollen wir doch mal dann wollen
wir doch mal sozusagen diese mangelnde öffentlichkeit gleich mal ein bisschen
adressieren wir sind ja quasi teil der öffentlichkeit wir machen podcast er
wird bei chaos radio erscheinen wir werden bestimmt auch diesmal wieder zumindest
ein teil des gesprächs transkribieren der kommt dann bei netzpolitik.org wunderbar
hat sie Aber warte auf meine fiese Frage.
Wir haben den Stand vom 27. November, also er ist noch relativ aktuell.
Ich sage nochmal das Datum, wir sind heute am 7. Dezember 2023.
Wenn ich von dir erwarten würde, nenn mir mal die drei kritischsten Punkte,
wo du unbedingt auch die Unterstützung einer kritischen Öffentlichkeit bräuchtest.
Welche würdest du nennen für den aktuellen Stand? Ich würde nennen,
ein sehr eingeschränkter Anwendungsbereich für die Konvention,
nämlich wirklich nur zugeschnitten.
Auf die Core Cyber Dependent Crimes. Also wirklich nur auf einen ganz engen
Anwendungsbereich an Straftatbeständen.
Und die müssen scharf formuliert sein, die müssen ganz genau formuliert sein
und hier darf es keinen Spielraum geben,
insbesondere was die Formulierung, das ist jetzt fürchte ich ein bisschen juristisch,
technisch, die Formulierung angeht des Vorsatzes.
So wie die Vorsatzformulierungen im Moment sind, beziehen Sie ethische Hacker,
beziehen Sie Journalisten, beziehen Sie Aktivisten mit ein.
Also es kann nicht ausgeschlossen werden, dass die auch unter Strafe gestellt werden.
Das zweite, was ich mir wünschen würde, sind stärkere, umfassendere Safeguards.
Wenn man sich die Konvention im Moment ansieht, so muss man feststellen,
dass die einzelnen Teile, in Österreich würden wir so sagen,
ein bisschen zusammengeschustert, also so zusammengesteckt wirken und man keinen roten Faden hat,
was jetzt Safeguards tatsächlich anwendbar sind, welche es gibt, welche anwendbar sind.
Das sind sehr generische, sehr, sehr breite Formulierungen.
Es braucht ganz konkrete Vorgaben, welche Mindestmaße an Sicherheitsmaßnahmen es gibt,
gerade im Hinblick auf die sehr weitreichenden, sehr stark eingreifenden Überwachungsmechanismen
und das auch noch in Kooperation mit der Möglichkeit, hier Rechtshilfe begehren zu stellen.
Das ist sehr wichtig. Ich würde mir eine sehr viel stärkere Datenschutzbestimmung
wünschen. Ist das schon Punkt 3?
Das kann man hier noch zu Punkt 2 sehen.
So wie sie hier momentan formuliert ist,
ist sie schwammig, sie stellt auf nationales Recht ab und sie ist absolut nicht
tauglich, entsprechenden Schutz unserer Daten sicherzustellen.
Punkt 3, im Allgemeinen.
Ein Einschränken der möglichen Überwachungsmechanismen, die es hier gibt.
Insbesondere keine Echtzeitüberwachung und eine Klarstellung,
dass nichts in die Richtung von einem Zulassen, also eines Aufweichens von Verschlüsselung
oder Zulassens durch die Hintertür von Spyware gelesen werden darf.
Es gibt viele Punkte, aber ich würde mir diese drei jetzt mal wünschen.
Naja schon, dass du diese drei nennst, deutet ja darauf hin,
dass da noch viel mehr kommen könnte, aber dass das die Schlimmsten sind.
Also ich finde ja schon mal gut, die alle ja schon so ein bisschen angesprochenen
Punkte jetzt nochmal priorisiert quasi zu haben.
Ich bin sie da rein nach durchgegangen, also nach dem Aufbau der Konvention.
Ich bin sie im Kopf durchgegangen, ich bin sie alle gleichwertig.
Ich kann nicht sagen, das eine ist wichtiger als das andere.
Tatsächlich nicht. Also liebe Tanja, vielen Dank erstmal dafür,
dass du uns diese Auskünfte gegeben hast, weil ich glaube, es gibt einfach sehr
wenige Menschen auf der Welt, die sich so intensiv damit beschäftigen und sozusagen
unseren Einblick geben.
Wir wollen natürlich unser Möglichstes tun, diese mangelnde Öffentlichkeit vielleicht
auch herzustellen, nicht wahr?
Genau und vielleicht versuchen wir dann nochmal rauszufinden,
wer in Deutschland dafür zuständig ist.
Wahrscheinlich sind das irgendwelche Menschen im Auswärtigen Amt,
würde ich jetzt mal vermuten. Ja, es gibt sogar eine Liste, man kann sich die
konkreten Namen... Justizministerium und Auswärtiges Amt, ja, ja.
Dann würde ich sagen, wir verlinken diese Liste mal und dann werden sie uns alle hassen.
Also ich fand es erstaunlich, dass die alle namentlich genannt sind,
auch aus allen Ländern. Also auch die namentlichen Vertreter.
Ja, ja, ja. Fand ich bemerkenswert.
Ja, es ist spannend, wie transparent, intransparent dieser ganze Prozess ist
und was dann öffentlich ist und was nicht.
Aber können ja vielleicht die Zuhörerinnen mal drüber nachdenken,
ob sie sich da nicht doch noch engagieren wollen, weil dann…,
Ich glaube, bei den Punkten, die Tanja genannt hat, da brauchen wir uns dann
fast keine Gedanken mehr über den Hacker-Paragrafen machen. Was uns da graut,
ist deutlich schlimmer wahrscheinlich.
Es hat Potenzial für Schlimmes, ja.
Genau. Erstmal vielen Dank, Tanja. Schön, dass du da warst.
Herzlichen Dank euch. Darfst du dich auch irgendwann nochmal mit etwas anderem
beschäftigen? Wir sind gespannt.
Auch das wird kommen, ja, natürlich. Oder wir reden mal darüber,
wie Policies in Österreich eigentlich entstehen, um dann die ganzen Menschen
komplett zu verwirren. Ja, genau.
Wir wünschen euch einen schönen Kongress, glaube ich, an dieser Stelle.
Ja, herzlichen Dank. Wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich auch auf dem Kongress.
Der 37C3 findet dieses Jahr nämlich wieder in Hamburg statt.
Und ganz vielleicht wird es da auch noch eine kleine dicke Bretter-Überraschung
geben, aber das ist noch nicht so ganz klar.
Da sprechen tun wir nicht, wir versuchen nur.
Ja, das mit dem Bohren ist halt auch nicht so einfach. In Saal 1 geht das bestimmt auch wieder nicht.
Genau. Vielen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wie immer werden wir bestimmt den Text
auf Netzpolitik jetzt, je nachdem wie schnell wir sind, parallel oder nachreichen.
Vielleicht auch noch so die ein oder andere Sache verlinken und ich würde glaube
ich schließen mit, beschäftigt euch mehr mit UN-Gesetzgebung,
weil New York und Wien ist eigentlich ganz nett, kann ich sagen.
Dann vielen Dank, Tanja und wir hören uns hoffentlich bei Dicke Brettler 6 im Jahr 2024.
Genau, bis dann. Ciao, ciao.
Music.